Good morning. Thank you for joining us for the Minorities in Cancer
Research Scientific Symposium entitled Ancestry Informed
Precision Oncology: Integrating Genomic Diversity into Cancer
Prevention and Treatment. My name is Melissa Davis.
I am the director of the Institute for Translational Genomic Medicine
at Morehouse School of Medicine and the immediate past chair of the MICR
Council. And I welcome you to this year's symposium, and thank you for joining
us.
Let's get started.
So today you'll hear from three dynamic speakers.
But before we get started, I just wanted to give some open remarks,
and really just set the stage for why this symposium is
really important.
If you've been a member of MICR for some time, then you know there's this
arc of evolution to the context and the questions that
we try to answer as a special interest group, but even
as professionals in the field and what our focus has been to try
to eliminate cancer disparities for many of us, but just
also provide innovative molecular approaches.
So over the last several years, our symposium has
traced a clear and important trajectory,
where in 2021, our focus was on
innovation and models that could move precision health
equity forward. Then we moved on in 2022, where the
conversation expanded to include the role of legislation and policy in
addressing disparities. In 2023,
we turned our attention to the innovation in oncology clinical
trials and to the persistent
problem
of underrepresentation.
In 2024, we confronted the promise and risk of multi-cancer
early detection, especially the possibility that new technologies
might even widen the gap of disparities if equity wasn't built into
it from the start.
And then lastly, most recently, the symposium asked us to think more
critically about how we use self-identified race in our
models in ethnicity and cancer disparities research.
And in the era of precision medicine, that is a very important discussion
to have, and we continue to have that conversation.
But what this arc really tells us is that the field has matured.
We no longer ask only whether disparities exist.
We are asking sharper questions, how they are produced, how they
are sustained, and how we intervene to change
outcomes, but with enough rigor to make that a sustainable change.
Okay.
We are moving from description to mechanism and from just
observation to the implementation and from broad
categories toward more precise understandings
of risk biology, the exposure, and the environment around us, as
well as the access and response that our populations have to
the therapeutics that are available to them.
Now, this evolution, in my opinion, matters because precision oncology
can't really fulfill its promise if the precision is
built on incomplete representation, built on those
blunt categories or frameworks that fail to account for human
diversity in all of its complexity.
And the challenge before us is not simply to make innovation more available, it's
to make sure innovation itself is more accurate, more
accountable, and more equitable.
And so what you'll hear from our speakers today is the application of
understanding how the genetic background of our complex human
diversity can actually be a tool for how we can identify
and reveal biological insights. And so I will hand the
mic over now to my co-chair to introduce our speakers,
and please join us in welcoming all of them,
and we'll also have a panel discussion in the end, so stay
tuned.
Thank you, Dr. Davis. It's a pleasure for me to
co-chair this symposium. As Dr. Davis said, we have three
outstanding speakers that'll cover three different areas.
Our first speaker will be Dr. Naisha Chambu, who's an assistant
professor at Feinstein Institute for Medical Research,
and she'll be talking about harnessing genomic diversity from
pangenomes to population health. Dr. Chambu.
Good morning, everybody, and thank you for making it to this room
so early today. I'd especially like to thank the session chairs for
the invitation to speak about our work today.
And so the topic of discussion that we're going to start with
is around reference genomes. And I've entitled this talk
"Gapless But Not Global: Ancestry-Enriched Functional
Sequence Still Missing from the Human Reference Genomes."
So, these are my requisite disclosures for the
conference. I still remember in
2001 the excitement to which the reference
genome release was received.
We, at this point, could envision a future where we could
map disease genes and really get at the underlying genetic basis of
disease and see a true path towards precision
medicine, and in our case in this audience, precision
oncologySo
every step in cancer genomic or cancer genomic
analysis really depends on having this key
resource of the reference genome.
And so we typically take our clinical or our research-grade
samples, match tumor or normal, we extract DNA,
sequence them, assess the quality of that sequencing product,
and then critically align those high-quality
reads to a reference genome. And so this really
determines what we believe the sequence we've obtained from
individuals who have cancer is, where it's mapped, whether it's not
mapped,
whether there's some discordant mapping, which results in a downstream
process where we'll call variants, annotate them for their
clinical significance, and report those out, for example,
in clinical genomics tests, which then determine a
clinical decision. This is the best-case scenario in
precision oncology. And so
underlying all of these procedures is the current
version of the human reference genome that is widely used, which is
GRCh38. So this remains the
predominant version that we use in research as well as in clinical
practice.
Just a little segue to say some people are still using hg19,
but we won't hold that against you.
So if we recall in 2001 when that reference genome was
released, I don't think we fully appreciated,
for example, the impact of who all was represented in
that initial map.
So to break that down, there was one individual of blended
ancestry, and then
19 individuals with predominant European ancestry.
So in essence, the reference genome is a patchwork of
complex admixtures that represent each
locus.
This version of the genome
has about 8% that is unresolved gaps.
So we know most of where the sequence is, but not all
of it, and this is really the basis of
what we know as annotated genetic sequence that's of clinical
significance, that we design therapeutic targets based on,
and that we develop, for example, lab-developed CLIA-approved
tests on.
So
since 2001, this human reference genome is not a static
measure. It's been continuously evolving through the efforts of
the Genome Reference Consortium over time to try and figure out those
gaps and close them. And with a significant
advance in 2002 from the Telomere to Telomere
Consortium that
put together a fully gapless reference genome,
T2T CHM13, which is a haploid
hytida form genome. And so you can see over time
from 2000 to 2022,
the amount of sequence that are represented in the reference
genome has grown until we have this fully resolved
gapless CHM13 version of the genome.
However, as you can appreciate from the previous slide, this
represents across all loci in the genome,
effectively one haplotype.
And so there's a new initiative now, the Human Pangenome
Reference
Consortium, to then diversify
gapless reference genomes. And so from that, we have a
phase one release, which is long-read gapless
reference assemblies across 47
individuals that more broadly represent global diversity.
Okay. And in this phase one release, we have 23 or so, about
51% of those reference assemblies are from African
ancestry individuals.
So what I'm going to talk about in essence today is an effort that was
inspired by the publication of this paper in 2018.
So in this paper, they published what was termed the first African
pangenome reference. What essentially they did in the study was
take a cohort, in this case it was a
asthma cohort with about 1,000, so
910 individuals of African ancestry.
They took whole genome sequencing from this cohort, aligned it
to GRCh38,
the version at the time, and took all these unmapped reads from
that experiment, assembled those reads into
contiguous sequences, which then amounted to
296 megabases of sequence that
they report to represent African ancestry-enriched sequence
not represented in GRCh38. So some of those
sequences, they could figure out where they mapped or where one end
placed. But because the sequence was so diverse, they couldn't exactly
place it on the framework of GRCh38
reference. And so essentially, these contiguous
sequences, which are referred to here as contigs,
represent African ancestry-enriched sequence that's not
represented in our current
reference genome framework.
So what are the implications for this?
So we went after this question by analyzing and
characterizing these APG contigs, these contiguous
sequences representing about 300 megabases of sequence.
We asked three main questions.
Given that we have newer references that are gapless, are those
sequences now represented?
Do they
encode functional sequence? And is there evidence that there's
biological activity in those missing sequences?And
so
our study design was as follows. We aligned these contigs,
about 125,000 of them to the T2T
CHM13 reference, as well as the 47 individual
HPRC gapless assemblies. And so there's a little
segue here to assess how well those alignments mapped.
And so for mapping thresholds, we
used the same metrics as was reported in
2019, where we take the contig sequence and align it to a
reference sequence.
In different references, CHM33 or CHM13
or HPRC, and we assess how well
that contig aligns. So it count how many bases are matched and the
relative identity, so how well they
exactly match. So we have two metrics of coverage
and identity. And then we take those metrics and
apply thresholds where we assign some alignments
as reasonably good, it's not exact or nearly
perfect. And this is the basis in which we assess these alignments.
And so we apply those thresholds I just described,
and then we categorize these contigs based on where they
annotate to, if there's ancestry enrichment or if we can
predict whether the sequence is functional in some way.
Okay. So the first result, we showed that
40% of these APG contigs map nearly
perfectly to T2T CHM13.
If we include the reasonably good alignments, we have
about...
Sorry, I'm doing math on the fly here.
Almost 80% are mapping
reasonably well to T2T. And we
can see that here represented on the right is
the amount of sequence that maps. And on the left here is
sequences that are unique to T2T CHM13 that are
not on GRCh38. And what you can
appreciate here is that this mapping is driven largely by
unique sequence that's in
CHM13 that's not represented in
GRCh38.
So where do these sequences map? So here's a global view across all
these chromosomes. So here in yellow, we have centromeric
sequences, in yellow unique T2T regions, and the
contigs in this reddish color. And you can see across the board,
there's largely these gaps we had seen in centromeres.
So that's 94% of these contigs that map to
T2T,
overlap centromeric or satellite repeat regions as you would
expect. However, it's not only in the repeat content
where we see these alignments, overlaps annotated genes
and annotated CpG islands, as well as composite
repeat elements. In particular, we zoomed into the
HLA locus where we noticed a lot of alignment activity in
this region with a vast majority of these previously
unmapped sequences mapping to the highly polymorphic and
diverse HLA region.
Okay, so these reference sequences are not just
noise or junk. They actually represent missing sequence
that's of functional consequence.
We took those annotated genes and performed gene set enrichment
analysis and observed an enrichment in
MHC complex protein driven
by that HLA locus, as well as neuronal processing and signaling.
We overlapped these genes with known disease
associations and found a significant number, as well as
hits for genetic predisposition to different traits
and diseases.
Because this was an asthma cohort, we saw significant enrichment of
asthma-associated GWAS hits,
signifying that if you simply use
GRCh38, you might be missing critical
disease-associated or predisposition genetic
variation in more diverse populations.
So in the next phase, we looked at how well
these sequences match the newer human pangenome
reference assemblies that are more diverse.
And as you can see here, the vast majority,
about 92 or so percent map to at least
one of the HPRC assemblies. And we looked at enrichment
of contig mapping relative to the ancestry of the
HPRC assembly, and we saw a significant enrichment
of alignment to African ancestry assemblies
or admixed American assemblies.
These
contigs are more likely to map to African or admixed American
references relative to East Asian, European, and South
Asian assemblies. So this population
scale resolution was fairly important and essential
for recovering sequences.
The most important thing we looked at was whether these sequences were
just simply repeats or they covered really
functionally active genomic regions.
So for the contigs that map to HPRC only assemblies,
you see the vast majority indeed represent repeat
elements, although we have a significant chunk here that are
not representative of a repeat sequence.
And because this is about 10.5 megabases, that
actually represented a significant amount of non-repeat sequence.
And so what we did was takePublicly available
RNA-Seq data use the contigs as a reference and
align RNA-Seq reads that didn't map to
GRCh38 and quantify relative expression
in these regions. For this exercise, we used one
non-cancer data set, the 1000 Genome cell lines RNA-Seq
data itself, as well as two cancer-related
cohorts from TCGA and one published from the Davis lab here.
And so we were able to quantify coverage of
RNA-Seq because there's no annotations on these HPRC assemblies,
and show relative enrichment and differences in expression
coverage, so RNA-Seq read coverage
across these contigs.
Lastly, there was that small subset of contigs that did not
map to T2T, did not map to GRCh38 or any
of the represented HPRC assemblies.
As you can see here, the vast majority did not represent repeat
sequences. And what we did here was try to use
computational prediction tools to predict the function of that sequence.
We predicted where CpG islands would be in genes.
And as you can see here, approximately
65% of those contigs,
about 1.5 megabases, represent potential functional
elements across the genome, even with protein domain
support in Pfam, et cetera.
So these sequences represent non-repetitive sequence
with coding and regulatory
features that exist outside of the current reference framework.
So you can see here we see widespread expression, not only in
the normal cell line, lymphoblastoid cell lines, but across
breast cancer
examples here. So in summary,
we are able to take close
to 300 megabases of African ancestry-enriched sequence that was
previously unmapped and show that it partially mapped to
T2T-CHM13, as well as at
least one of the current phase one HPRC assemblies.
We recovered sequences that overlap genes, immune loci, CpG
islands, et cetera, as well as known disease-associated loci.
There was a strong ancestry enrichment across these
alignments, and that for sequences that remain unmapped
to all the represented references, they were not in
repeat enriched, but contained predicted coding and
regulatory features that showed evidence of transcriptional
activity.
Okay. So in conclusion, we need to really think about your
reference genome use. Just because the reference is gapless does
not mean it's representative of your given population.
And this has staggering consequences for precision oncology,
including affecting somatic variant calling,
neoantigen or HLA typing, et cetera, as well as our ability
to detect biomarkers in certain populations.
And so I will end with these set of practical
recommendations that we need to have a more measured
approach to
reporting what we do with the reference build we use, including
exploring the use of multi-reference or graph-based pangenomes
in cancer genomics workflows.
So in conclusion, reference bias is not just about fairness, it's
also sensitivity. If you have missing sequence, you might miss biology
that's pertinent to making a clinical decision.
And so we should shift to think about
sequence completeness
relative to population representativeness.
I went through a very complex set of analyses.
You can read about it more widely on this publication.
This work was led by Rachel Martini in Dr.
Davis's lab and Abdul Tajuddeen Shijani and Kyriaki
Fountain in my group. A strong collaboration where we were funded through the
McMillen Center for the study of the non-coding cancer genome.
And these are my wider acknowledgments. Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Dr. Chambless. That was terrific.
We have time set aside at the end for questions, so
we'll hold questions until then.
Our next speaker is Dr. King Jordan, who's professor at
Georgia Institute of Technology, and he's going to discuss
epigenetics, ancestry, and cancer disparity, when nature
might be nurture.
Dr. Jordan.
All right. Thank you very much. Melissa and Electron, thank you for the
invitation to present our results here.
So you just heard I'm going to talk about epigenetics
along the axis of ancestry as a
potential resolution to that longstanding paradox of
nature versus nurture. And just as a bit of a preview, I'm going to tell you it's
not really nature versus nurture, it's nature and
nurture. Now, they told us it was very important to have a disclosure
slide, and when I prepared my slides, I thought, "I have nothing to
disclose." And then I heard Niesha's talk, and I have an embarrassing
disclosure, Niesha, is that all of this was done with HG-19.
Now, I don't take the blame for that. It's a TCGA thing.
It's a cancer thing, but your point is well taken. That was really interesting.
So take it with a grain of salt. Okay, so cancer survival
disparities. There's good news and not so good news.
The good news is that there's really been a precipitous
drop in mortality from cancer, especially over the last 10 or
20 years. Unfortunately, survival
disparities stubbornly persist, especially for Black
patients. They have the highest all cancer mortality rate for a
number of very common cancers that really impose a
substantial burden of both morbidity and
mortality on the population. So this is really
just a stubborn problem that we haven't been able to resolve
yet, unfortunately. SoWith respect to the
study that I'm going to describe to you, what we wanted to do as it relates to
cancer survival disparities is study the relationship between
disparities, ancestry, and what TCGA and others call
tumor molecular signatures. Okay?
So for ancestry, and this is also related to what Melissa talked about, about
these kind of broad groups and can we do better moving away from the course groups.
We looked at patient self-identified race and ethnicity, and we looked at
genetically inferred ancestry, which is a characteristic of the genome.
And with respect to genetic ancestry, we characterized it as both a
categorical and continuous variable.
For tumor molecular signatures, we looked at somatic mutations, differential
expression, and differential methylation. Okay?
And a couple of questions we had were, are cancer survival
disparities better delineated by self-identified race and
ethnicity or genetic ancestry, right?
And so the idea is that since self-identified race and ethnicity are socially
defined, if they better delineate disparities, perhaps social
factors might be more important. On the other hand, since
genetic ancestry, again, is a characteristic of the genome, if they delineate
disparities better, maybe molecular factors are more relevant.
As it relates to the tumor molecular signatures, we wanted to know which
of those signatures are most associated with cancer survival
disparities. Okay? So this was a pan-cancer
analysis, with NCI TCGA data.
I ding them a little bit for HD19, but it's really a wonderful
resource. So there's 33 different tumor types, 11,000
patients, seven different patient
data types. So what we did was we combined genetic
ancestry inference with epidemiological modeling.
And so for our models, the outcomes was overall survival data,
alive versus death events. And then we had a number of different
predictor variables. We had genomic data from arrays that we used for genetic
ancestry analysis. We had whole-genome sequence data, which we
used to characterize
somatic mutations, differences between germline and cancer tissue mutations.
We had RNA-seq data for differential gene expression and Illumina
Infinium Array data for differential methylation data.
And here is our cohort, with the self-identified race and
ethnicity of the TCGA patients or participants.
So all the patients that were enrolled in TCGA,
like many of us who fill out forms using the OMB standards,
which recently have changed, were asked to self-identify both their
race,
as well as their ethnicity as Hispanic or not Hispanic.
And so our overall cohort was almost 10,000
patients,
that about 1,000 of those had missing self-identified race or ethnicity
data.
As it relates to genetic ancestry, what we did, this is typical for genetic
ancestry inferences. We took the samples from TCGA, and we
compared the cohort, the variation there to global
reference populations characterized as part of the 1000 Genomes Project
and the Human Genome Diversity Project.
So we had a reference panel of several thousand individuals from
populations all over the world.
And here is the first result. So we're looking at the relationship between
TCGA patient self-identified race and ethnicity,
and genetic ancestry. So you see the reference populations
here. One thing I want to call your attention to is that even though these are
reference populations, their ancestry is not completely coherent.
So on both of these graphs, you're looking at the ancestry proportion on the
y-axis, and then stacked bar charts, which show each individual's
proportion of ancestry. Here are the TCGA
patients. The vast majority of them self-identified as white, but we
also had not insubstantial numbers with respect to resolution
for analysis of Black, Hispanic, and Asian patients.
All of these groups show group-specific patterns of
genetic ancestry, albeit with a substantial amount
of variation in ancestry within the groups.
As it relates to categorical ancestry, here is a PCA plot,
and what we've done is we've just labeled the individuals, again, with respect to
their self-identified race and ethnicity versus genetic
ancestry groups. There's a lot of similarity here, but what you can
see is that the patterns in sire are more diffused, there's more overlap,
the boundaries are more fuzzy, whereas with genetic ancestry, which is
defined by a K Nearest Neighbor clustering algorithm
unsupervised on the PCA data, the groups are
more coherent.
And then if you just quantify that, here we're quantifying the relationship
again between how patients identify their
race or ethnicity versus genetic ancestry, again, a characteristic of the
genome. And for three out of the four largest groups, there's quite
a bit of overlap, 95%, 90%, 94%. The
exception is the Hispanic group, where there's substantially
less overlap consistent with the fact that this is an ethnic designation as
opposed to self-identified race.
So having said all that, now we wanted to move on to the epidemiological
modeling. We started with univariable modeling as a first pass just to
identify cancer disparities. We identified significant
disparities in four different kinds of cancer.Breast cancer,
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma, kidney cancer, and skin
cancer. And here you see a comparison of the patterns of
differences in survival for SIRE, self-identified race and
ethnicity on the top, genetic ancestry on the bottom.
And you see that consistent with the overlap with respect to how people
identify and their ancestry groups, the patterns are quite similar,
but if you squint, you can also see that you begin
to see some differences there. So having identified those disparities using
univariable analysis, we moved on to multivariable analyses using
Cox proportional hazard modeling.
Don't worry, I'm not going to belabor all of these models in the interest of time.
What I want to stress here is that what we're doing is we
are modeling the association of ancestry with
survival, controlling for relevant clinical and
demographic covariates, age, sex, tumor condition, and
we're doing so for SIRE, as well as genetic ancestry
modeled as both a categorical and a continuous variable.
We have a general set of models which are the same across all cancers, and then
we have cancer-specific models which include additional
cancer-specific covariates like menopause for breast cancer and
different stratification as need be.
And when we do that, we see similar results that we saw for the univariable
models, albeit more resolved. So one of the disparities
that I'm going to really focus on as I close out the talk is breast
cancer, which is associated with African ancestry, not a surprise to
Melissa because her own group has shown that years ago.
And overall,
there's a lot going on in this slide here.
So basically again, you have this comparison between SIRE and genetic ancestry.
And what I just want to emphasize is that here with the multivariable
models, now you can begin to see that, yes, again, there are
similarities with respect to the associations between either ancestry or
SIRE and the survival.
So there are six pairwise comparisons that yielded
statistically significant associations with ancestry between pairs
of groups, and that were consistent for modeling ancestry as both a
categorical and a continuous variable.
But only three of those six were significant with SIRE.
A lot of those look like this situation with breast cancer here, where again, the
pattern is very, very similar, but there's just a little bit less
resolution as it relates to SIRE, and therefore a lack of
statistical significance there compared to the genetic ancestry results.
So,
now that we have established that genetic ancestry, both as a
categorical and a continuous variable where we can get more variation,
yields more signal, then we move on to ask, moving forward
now just with genetic ancestry, to ask, how does genetic
ancestry and these tumor molecular signatures
interact to affect the observed cancer survival disparities?
And again, just by way of reminder, those tumor molecular signatures are somatic
mutations, differential expression, and differential
methylation. And here what we're doing is a very similar
multivariable modeling, where now we're modeling, controlling for
covariates, the effect of ancestry, the effect of a
tumor molecular signature, any one of the signatures across the
gene, and importantly, an interaction term.
So do those tumor molecular signatures interact with
ancestry to affect the survival outcomes?
And a lot of that is just if you add this term into the model, do you get a better
model fit? Okay? So first, for somatic mutations, there
were a lot of somatic mutations overall.
Somatic mutation is obviously very important in cancer.
But when it comes to genetic ancestry, there were not a lot of
differentially mutated genes that were associated with genetic ancestry, at least
in this data set. And none of the differentially mutated genes showed
significant interactions with genetic ancestry on survival outcomes.
So at least for this data set, the cancer survival disparities are not
so much related to group-specific mutation.
The story was quite different when we looked at gene expression.
So there were lots of cases of differential gene expression
between ancestry groups for all of those pairs that showed
cancer survival disparities. And when we
included those as interaction terms in the model, we
found seven protein coding genes that are associated with cancer survival
disparities via interactions between genetic
ancestry and differential expression.
I told you before, I wanted to focus on breast cancer, which is I think
perhaps the most interesting story that we pulled out here.
Five of those genes
were for breast cancer, and they were all upregulated in the
African ancestry group compared to European
ancestry group. And all of these genes have been previously implicated in tumor
genesis, and I'm going to talk more about PAQR6.
So having shown that it's really not about
somatic mutations, there's a lot of action going on in
differential expression. Finding those seven genes, five in the case
of breast cancer, that interact with genetic ancestry to shape cancer
survival disparities. Then we added in the differential methylation.
The first thing we did was we ensured that the patterns of methylation were
consistent with what we saw with respect to differential expression.
In other words, was hypomethylation associated
or correlated with upregulation of genes of interest?
Again, a lot going on here, but I'm just going to focus on PAQR6.
So what you're looking at is the relationship between the log two-fold
change, the difference in expression between ancestry groups
upregulated here in the positive side of the
X-axis, and the change in the hazards ratio for the
model when we add in methylation to the model.
Okay? So again, PAQR6
is differentially expressed, upregulated in the
African ancestry group and associated with cancer survival
disparities when introduced as an interaction term into the
model. And then when you add in methylation, the hazard
ratio changes significantly. Okay?
So the idea is that hypomethylation of the promoter region for the
PAQR6 gene in African ancestry patients is
associated with both higher gene expression and a greater
risk of breast cancer mortality compared to European ancestry
patients. And the PAQR6 gene encodes a progesterone
receptor that has been shown to mediate progestin-induced
inhibition of apoptosis in breast cancer cells.
And it's also been shown to be associated with cancer and
worse outcomes in a couple other cancers, prostate cancer and kidney
cancer as well.Okay
So those are the data. And now with your permission, I
am going to speculate wildly with another disclosure or caveat
is that we don't have data to support these speculations. Right?
These data we believe
perhaps could tell us this, but we really need more data to tease
this apart. Okay So
scientists have been long interested in this question of the relative importance of
nature, genetics versus nurture, the environment for health disparities.
There's a lot of debate around this.
In our study, what we found is that changes in gene expression that are
mediated by epigenetic mechanisms have a greater contribution
to cancer survival disparities than group specific genetic
variants. Okay? And this is consistent with a previously proposed
role for epigenetics and health disparities.
So that idea, that epigenetics health disparities hypothesis, is
that epigenetic changes, DNA methylation can be altered
based on specific environmental exposures.
These could be pollution, psychosocial stress, all kinds of different exposures,
which may be linked to racial and ethnic differences in both the
exposure levels and the health outcomes.
So what I'm proposing here, again, speculating, is that epigenetics
could be a link between group specific environmental
exposures and genetically influenced pathophysiological
states that are implicated in health disparities.
In other words, it's not nature versus nurture, it's nature and
nurture with epigenetics as a key link between
the two.
So that's what I got. And with that, I want to thank the members of my group,
especially Cara Lee. This was all of her work, part of her
PhD thesis. This work was done in collaboration with the
National Institute on Minority Health and Health Disparities, Leonardo
Marino
and Lawanya Rashishwar. So
I guess we'll do questions later. Thank you for your attention.
Excellent. Thank you, Dr. Jordan. Our next speaker is Dr.
Clayton Yates, who's a professor at John Hopkins School of Medicine, and
he's going to be talking about translating genomic
equity, building infrastructure for global precision oncology.
Dr. Yates.
Thank you.
I do have a few disclosures. So I think
Dr. Shumway, as well as Dr. Jordan, was able to go through
and make a case for why we are studying the disparities, even Dr.
Davis opened us up by now that we understand that there are disparities,
how do we actually dig in and translate into solving them?
And so,
over some time, in collaboration with
Stefan Anz at the NCI, we've been utilizing
what is called the NCI Maryland Cohort.
And this is a comprehensive cohort that has many layers.
As you can see here,
exposomics, GWAS, proteomics, single cell sequencing, clinical
pathological data, as well as questionnaire data and geographical data.
Today I'm going to talk about sort of three of those,
and
at the end,
hopefully detail how we're going to integrate those and
actually use that in precision, particularly associated with precision
pathology.
Oh, wrong way. All right, so, as you
surmised, again, from the previous two talks, that it is
clear that patients who have African ancestry have some
dysregulated immune response. So in our group, what we asked,
we did Olink analysis, which is a serum proteomics.
And what we looked at, and these were actually healthy individuals.
We wanted to understand what was the inflammatory roles and was that localized to
the tumor or is it associated with circulation?
And so what we clearly saw here was that there was ancestry associated increase
in tumor suppressive signatures, and these is actually Native African Ghanaian
patients as well as African Americans, and you can see that decrease.
We saw an increased hypersensitivity of enriched pathways such as
tumor immunity.
When we actually looked at what those elevated cytokines, you can
appreciate a number of these, particularly like the CXCL5,
CXCL1s, as well as macrophage recruitment proteins one and two,
are all associated with African ancestry.
But we also saw a number of other genes that weren't associated with African
ancestry, but also upregulated.
Because this was a case control study, in addition
to the healthy donors, we also probed cancer patients.
And again, you can see this tumor suppressive profile was
associated with all-cause mortality, particularly
in the cancer patients as well as cancer specific
mortality.
To understand what that means, because again, this is a broad group.
Again, this was circulating cytokines.
We wanted to understand, can we actually drill down to something that was
predictive? And so again, Dr. Jordan showed you the
value of
Cox modeling. So we performed mass cross rejection, Cox
model and regression models, and we accounted for multiple variants, not just the
gene association, but also ancestry, BMI, smoking, diabetes
status, because remember this cohort had a large questionnaire
availability. And what we were able to come up with was a robust predictive
signature that predicts lethal cancers, not necessarily incidents, but
the patients who would progress particularly in
patients with African ancestry. And so these were the two genes here.
So if you look at this TNSFR9 as well as PTEN,
these predict outcome specifically in
patients with African ancestry. It does not have the sensitivity in European
ancestry individuals, and it does that with 78.2%
accuracy. If you actually then combine NCCN score plus
our two gene signature, you can get up with 90% accuracy.
This is a major advance for prostate cancer because
most men, if you live long enough, for guys in the room, you're going to get
prostate cancer, right? So this is an issue of prostate growth in a large way.
The question becomes which patients are most aggressive and which ones we should
monitor, and we feel like we have some inroads in understanding and identifying
thatSo as I mentioned before, again, utilizing
the NCI cohort, the next question we wanted to ask,
how is this associated with social determinants, particularly neighborhood
deprivation? So again, thinking about this, this is a catchment
area in Maryland. And Maryland having a
predominantly
higher NDI associated population.
These were the patients in the catchment area for all the participants that you
will see in the study.
So if you take the inflammatory signature that we derived from the Olink and you
overlay that with social determinants, particularly NDI status, again,
you can appreciate that even in control individuals,
this high level of inflammation is associated with a higher NDI.
And obviously you can see that exacerbated in cancer patients.
Then if you actually take the number of our sort of driver genes that we think were
predictive of aggressiveness in tumor, and you ask how those associated with
West African ancestry and neighborhood deprivation, you sort of see this
conundrum where we see the PTN actually, as well as
the CXCL5 and CXCL1 are both associated with ancestry and neighborhood
deprivation. So we're starting to understand the impact of the
environment. The NDI, the social determinants but also
genetic ancestry and how that interplays in how patients present.
So the next part of what we wanted to understand, if this is happening
systemically, what is happening to the cells?
So we have cytokines in
circulation, but there's also cells that
should be responsive to these elevated levels of cytokines.
So Samuel Mbunwe in my lab,
as well as Isidro Cortes,
we analyzed our circulating cytokines in addition
to our PBMC cohort. So we did single cell sequencing on
PBMC. We ran self-reported race as well as
ancestry on all those individuals.
Actually, Isidro's lab developed the ancestry pipeline, particularly for
single cell sequencing data. And as you can imagine, a number of our patients
had greater than 70% West African ancestry.
Also, it's well established, the dark gene, particularly the DFAL allele, which
is actually being explored
greatly by the Davis lab. We use that as a second layer of
ancestry to understand, particularly with the elevated cytokines, how that was
associated with our cells response, particularly at the cell type level.
So if you can start to appreciate, if you think about all the cell types in
circulation, we were able to pull out a number of cell types,
particularly CD16 monocytes, as well as T
cells that were highly expressed in African Americans.
And if you, again, think about
how a protein in circulation would influence the differentiation of an individual
cell type.
We did ligand receptor mapping, and if you see here, you see the
dark associated cytokines, particularly the CXCL1, CXCL5, and
MCP proteins that we showed earlier that were much higher in
patients of African ancestry or Doprino.
Here is the impact on the cells. So in a number of cell types,
particularly the dendritic cells, macrophages, and monocytes, all are
significantly impacted and not in their
undifferentiated state that you would expect in healthy individuals or
particularly in cancer patients. And this is happening systemically.
If you drill this down to what we thought was important, and this is a manuscript
that we have under review now, we pulled out a
CD8 TEM signature score that seemed to have increased
association with all-cause mortality and also prostate-specific
mortality. And so again, this is also statistically
important because not only are these CD8 positive cells, they also
co-express exhaustion markers such as LAG-3.
So again, a number of these exhaustion markers are targetable
in tumor cells, but now we're showing that this is also extremely important in
circulation, and it's much higher in African ancestry individuals.
So we next wanted to look at what is actually happening in the tumor,
so we could develop the cohort as well as including native African men as well as
the Maryland cohort. And we also did spatial profiling and single cell sequencing
and multi-omes. So again, in this patient cohort, we have around
185 individuals that have high versus low African
ancestry. What you can start to appreciate here, if you look at
native Nigerian, and we actually stratify for subpopulation of
Yoruba. So all African Americans, as well as Nigerian,
have Yoruba ancestry backgrounds.
You still see a major difference is in the African American
versus a native African. And to, again, Dr.
Jordan's point here in the... Oh, sorry, they shifted over a little bit.
But the individuals who self-reported race and ancestry actually don't correlate.
We see a little bit of also gene expression change, and so we're exploring those
with Dr. Shumway's lab doing methylseq and methylation analysis.
Next, we wanted to understand what those differential gene expressions, so we did
CIBERSORT deconvolution analysis.
And again, what you can appreciate, if you're comparing self-reported race versus
ancestry, we see this enrichment, particularly in high African
ancestry, African-American, as well as Nigerian tumors, with increase in some of
these myeloid-derived cells. We see that lower association
with high African ancestry. And if we look at this and
determine if this is also correlated with the TCGA, we see that as well.
So you see monocytes much higher in African Americans than
African ancestry, as well as certain types of T cells, and we see also
M1 macrophages. So we think that's hopefully creating this inflammatory
response as well as tumor suppressor.
The next question we wanted to ask
if
this was actually systemic or around the periphery or actually in the tumor mass.
So we did ancestry informed analysis on laser capture
macrodissected sections. And again, this is ancestry informed
CIBERSORT
deconvolution. And again, we see even within the tumor
parenchyma, you see these upregulation of MK cells
as well as macrophages. We didn't see a lot of stroma, but this is
not surprising. Again, these was all macrodissected tumor-enriched areas.
But we were able to see that these African American tumors show clearly suppressed
immune polarized states, particularly in the M1 as well as M2
macrophages. So this is not just happening on the periphery, it's actually
happening in tumor intrinsic.So that led us to a
subsequent question. So if this is really happening in the tumor and we see this
sort of gene expression changes, what is making the tumor
actually be associated with that? So again, we did multi-ome sequencing.
So this is single-cell sequencing as well as single-cell ATAC-seq, where we're
actually looking at the chromatin, the transcription factor regulation in
correlation with gene expression of individual cells.
And we had an African American cohort and a European cohort.
And we had stratified Gleason score.
All of these were Gleason score, but just a little bit of prostate cancer biology.
Four plus three is a seven, but if that's a higher aggressive tumor, so it's
categorized as aggressive. Three plus four is still a seven, but it's
considered non-aggressive. So we had a mixed cohort of aggressive versus
non-aggressive tumors. And again, just sort of looking at this interplay
between RNA expression as well as chromatin remodeling.
So again, if you can appreciate here, we have African American patients who have a
robust number of myeloid cells compared to Europeans.
That's what we saw in our
bulk RNA-seq deconvolution data.
And now we were able to confirm that from single-cell patient data.
If you look at the gene expression, all of those immune inflammatory genes,
STAT genes, STAT3, which are transcriptional regulators, as well as
other immunophytatory genes are robustly expressed in
these patients. Again, all of these are African American
tumors. And if you start to look at what is the transcription factors, again,
in these individual cells expressed in these
cell types, you start to see clearly the STAT,
CEBP, CBPE genes, all the
interferon genes at the chromatin level driving this sort of
myeloid-specific differentiation in the tumor.
And because we had high versus low, what does that mean?
These sort of myeloid predictive patterns, particularly in this sort of TAM
lipid
cell type, are predictive of a patient that has that sort of
non-aggressive versus aggressive tumor type.
And so the last thing, because I think I mentioned before, I'm a molecular
pathologist, so we actually want to see these cells.
The sequencing data's good, but can I see this in a tumor?
So in addition to that, we started to develop a deep learning model called
CODA that was pioneered by Kelly. Oh, sorry, this
is a little bit cut off, but actually Kevin at Johns Hopkins, and this is our
pathologist, Ezra. And so essentially what we're doing is we're taking serial
sections from H&E stains. We're single cell registering all of that so we can
capture all of the heterogeneity at the H&E level.
Javon here is a post-bac. His job was it.
He actually had to scan in 6,000 slides because we trained it on 6,000
slides over 100 or so cases, 3,000 training set, 3,000 validation
set, mixed with African American versus European.
And this is what it looks like when you start to pull it together.
So now we're sort of moving from this individual layer
of an H&E to a 3D format. And if you could start to think about
if you can identify individual cell types, we can pseudocolor those, and we can
start to look at what an African American looks like in three-dimensional with that
clear level of infiltration, which is clearly depicted here
in this purple, versus a European tumor that
has low levels of inflammatory inflammation.
And a little bit just about the model.
We're about to finish this up, but we segmentated it.
Not only did we train it to identify inflammatory cells, but
other cellular cell types such as stroma,
vasculature, tumor, as well as fat cells.
Now we've actually moved on to spatial transcriptomics.
And so you can think about if you can
utilize a deep learning model to identify individual cell types, and again,
these are
AI-identified cell types. You can then mirror that with spatial
transcriptomics such as Visium analysis, and then you can integrate
those back into the H&E so that we can start to understand what a
cell's morphology looks like, what its transcriptome looks like, and actually what
its protein expression looks like in the same individual cell.
And I'll just end with a little bit of a highlight.
Samuel has a poster this afternoon, so please go by and check it, where we're
starting to develop CODA2, so it's called CODA Pivot now,
in the lab, where we're developing
algorithms to be able to take, again, H&E status,
Visium, single cell, and this is CD163, which again, is
a macrophage myeloid marker. But be able to do this at the
single-cell registry based from the transcript, all the way from the
RNA, and overlay that with the protein so we can start to
understand where those levels of infiltration in the tumor are so
that we can capture the heterogeneity as well.
And what we are seeing here is that we see much higher CD163
in African American, as well as LAG-3, that we also saw in circulation.
We now can replicate that in the tumor cells compared to European.
So I'll just end there because Dr. Davis told me to stay on time, which I'm
almost-- She knows I'll go over our time.
But in summary,
we feel like we're starting to resolve
an important question. Prostate tumors have been immunologically cold.
They have not been able to benefit from immune therapy.
Hopefully, we can convince you today that we see robust numbers of immune cells,
not only in circulation, but also infiltrating in tumor.
And we think these patients to start to benefit from the
vast knowledge that we have of many types of immunotherapy, if we can
start to pinpoint those and revisit this, particularly for patients of African
ancestry. And the second thing is that we see that both
systemically as well as in tumor circulation, and then this is just the model of
our lab. We just have to take a holistic approach.
And I
probably went over one minute, but this is the focus of our lab, is that we're
thinking about people as individuals, not as cases that we just
studied in genomic data. These are our major collaborators who are responsible for
all the work and the funding sources. So thank you.
Thank you to all the speakers for a wonderful job staying on time.
This is a question session, so those
in the audience, feel free to come up to the front or back mic
to ask questions.
A fantastic talk. Thank you so much.
Really, really exciting and very interesting work.
My question is regarding the fact that you see high infiltration
within the tumors, but you also see this
anti-inflammatory, pro-tumoral M2 macrophage
phenotype that's present. Do you think that that's driven by chronic
inflammation?
And I'm asking just because it's a little bit paradoxical there.
You're seeing higher tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes, but overall, the tumor
microenvironment is more anti-inflammatory.
So do you think that's driven by chronic inflammation as the tumor is being
developed, or any thoughts on that?
No, I think it's a great question, and we ask ourselves that question all the time.
In fact, it's almost inherent in the study design.
So we think what's happening is clearly this sort of
environmental trigger of inflammation, right?
That's associated with biology, things like DARC, dopey, no status.
That's creating this increased environment.
But the body can't stay in an inflammatory state all the time, right?
So we're seeing this sort of mix of these sort of pressures
increase inflammation that's associated with this M1.
You saw M1 macrophages, which are supposed to be innate.
So the response of they were higher, but over time, they sort of become
suppressed because they just can't stay on all the time.
And so then that creates this tumor niche.
Now, when we start looking at the pathology, we see a mix.
So we see M1 niches in the tumor associated with more
the sort of active, and then we see the M1 associated with co-localized suppressed
T cell exhaustion as well. So that's why we're utilizing our coding 3D models to
start to resolve that within the spatial context.
Mm-hmm. Do you think there's a connection there?
And this is just something I've been thinking about.
If there does so happen to be
chronic inflammation that's driving
immunosuppressive
polarization of macrophage populations, I think there could be some
fundamental questions we need to ask about the way we model cancer.
Most cancer is modeled in this kind of almost like a
vaccine, like we're inoculating mice with tumors.
Yeah.
And we're not really capturing this chronic inflammation that would
cause the polarization of these immune cell populations.
Do you think there's anything that we could do to kind of change that?
Because, I
think the obvious answer would be
sampling patients over time, but that's not always
affordable, that's not always accessible. So what are your thoughts on that?
The things that come to mind, I can't say right now
on the mic.
But from a scientific perspective, yeah, I think what the data was
showing, which actually surprised me.
Those first slides were healthy individuals,
right? So we're talking about 1,500 healthy individuals.
It was exacerbated in the cancer patients, but these are healthy.
So yes, I think we have to rethink what is happening, and we
also went through painstakingly
analysis to see that was also associated with neighborhoods.
So if you start thinking about what are we doing in our environments,
right? All the other factors that we know that contribute to that and how that
influences that patient actually before they get cancer, because we see when they
get cancer. That's why we think it's off to the races, because it was already like
a primed system.
Fantastic. Thank you so much.
That was
great. Thank you.
I was just curious, so when we measure ancestry, we do it in this global way,
right? Percentages. But we know the genome isn't quite just
uniformly
75, 25.
Are you all thinking about local ancestry or areas of...
And how are you
measuring that? Like, Dr. King, you found that gene, and are you
exploring that from a global or local ancestry
and incorporating that into your analyses?
Yeah, great question. Thank you for that.
So I really tried to emphasize today the advantage of studying
genetic ancestry because you can characterize it as a categorical variable or
a continuous variable. But in reality, I barely scratched the surface, right?
Because I was just looking at continental ancestry.
We also have results on subcontinental ancestry.
So another great thing about ancestry is you can characterize it at different
levels of resolution. And in addition, everything I talked about today is what we
call genome-wide ancestry. So the short answer to your question is yes, we are
absolutely interested in local ancestry.
And with respect to local... And so you can have individuals that
have the same, say, African American, 80% African,
20% European, same genome-wide ancestry, but very
different patterns of local ancestry.
One of the really interesting things about local ancestry is
that
there's a randomization at meiosis, right?
It's like a special case of Mendelian randomization, if you're
familiar with that technique. Whereas you've got the two parents and whichever
chromosome that
is inherited by the offspring is random, right?
So what we're trying to do in different studies in different contexts is take
advantage of that natural experiment, that randomization that occurs at meiosis
to associate local ancestry with health outcomes in a way that is
not confounded by environmental variables because that
randomization at meiosis decouples that association. Yeah.
Cool. Thank you.
Hey, everyone. So I had a comment and question for Clayton.
Nice work, always. You know what I'm interested in, neutrophils, right?
So one thing, that CD16 monocyte population, I actually kind of
wonder if it might be on the spectrum because CD16 is a big
marker for mature neutrophils. And there is this population in
the cancer patients where they can be monocytic like
granulocytes-
Yeah
... that have some suppressive effects.
Yeah.
I'm not sure if you're aware of it, but you might want to think about it because it
could be an interesting phenotype in your data that you're seeing.
So I skipped over the neutrophils because I'm going to just send that to you.
Okay.
All right. But no, there's actually clearly a heightened
level of neutrophil infiltration, particularly in our macrodissected.
It was interesting, though, when we did sort of the bulk analysis where we didn't
microsect it, we didn't see as many neutrophils.
But in the macrodissected tumors, the ones that I take, it's absolutely
enriched in neutrophils.
That was in the tumor population. In
circulation, yeah, we saw the CD16.
We
think they're sort of primary. It probably is going to depend on what cytokine is
being exposed. Obviously, we captured some of the dark associated cytokines, and we
kind of went down that sort of monocytic, dendritic,
as well as sort of myeloid, other more like cells.
But if you start to look at pressures of other circulating cytokines, we may see
that neutrophil in circulation as well. Absolutely.
Mm-hmm.
There's a lot to be done.
So the other question I had was, have you stratified for therapy?
So I was wondering, in your tumor patients, do you stratify for those that have
been treated with androgen deprivation therapy, and do you see an impact on the
immune populations that come out?
So, here's the conundrum in prostate tumors.
So everything we did was treatment naive.
Okay.
All right. So all that was treatment naive.
Now,
I think I mentioned before, so
prostate tumors typically present the classical response, and most of the
Europeans present as immunologically cold. Obviously, we think ours are hot.
I used to have a slide that said prostate tumors are hot.
However, enzalutamide,
particularly as they get to progressive therapy or they fail, they
relapse.
Yeah.
That's when you see, even in a European ancestry individual, you'll see an influx
of those immune cells, and they look like our African Americans that presented
in treatment naive setting.
Oh, okay.
But after castration resistance-
Okay
... in the European population.
All right. Good to know. Okay. Thanks.
Sorry.
I have a follow-up question for Dr. Yates while we're on that topic.
In your analysis of the
transcription factors, there was a group that were
endothelial specific, and I was just curious, are you seeing any of
the phenotypes that you see the, I guess, the
immunological infiltration? Is that affiliated
with the actual presence of endothelial cells or
angiogenesis in those tumors?
We haven't gotten that far. So in our code analysis, we actually
included endothelial cells as mapping morphology.
We have not gone through endothelials to confirm it by marker expression
in the Visium data yet, but yes, we could.
Hi, Christina Freedenberg, University of Florida. Building off of Dr.
Gbadamosi's question,
he's from UF. Go Gators.
He talked about kind of the inflammatory process that happens,
and so I'm wondering if you are combining, Dr.
Yates, your clinical pathologic data, so
patients that have chronic prostatitis, patients that have
BPH or PEN, age-related changes that might be associated with
a higher inflammatory infiltrate versus individuals who
are younger. So are you integrating that
information in your model?
Not yet.
Okay.
Like I said, it was a lot of work to get those slides candid.
But what I can tell you in the data we have now, and I didn't show it today,
we see a huge amount of these immune cells.
So if you sort of think about the African Americans, we actually saw this sort of
mixed
tumor infiltration around the tumor.
But the adjacent sort of benign glands filled with
high levels of T cell inflammation, right?
And that was much more in the African American. I didn't show it today as well.
But yeah, it's something where it puzzled me, and I didn't appreciate it
until I saw the actual spatial data,
and we need to dig into what they're doing, why they're hanging out in the benign
glands.
I know Christy has a pathology-
Yeah, sorry. Did you also look at the PSA, like their pre...
That's just something to think about because maybe there, you do have this chronic
prostatitis-
Right
... phenomena that builds into a cancer.
So there is that etiology that can start to brew.
But that's...
Sorry.
Can I add a quick postscript? You might not know, but there's two UGA
Bulldogs on this podium. So I can't let that go Gators
go without a go Dogs, and I'm sorry about the NCAA tournament, by the
way.
Y'all just need to stop. I'm Big Ten, so
sports is not ready. Football's coming.
So I'm Janine Ferraro, NCI. I have, I guess a
comment question, for Dr. Wood, I believe.
You showed that the potential gene may be progesterone receptor
related. And
we recently published that the incidence rates for ER-negative breast cancer
seem to be very similar to what we see in the Ghana
population at the exact same time period.
And I'm wondering, I know you adjusted in your
models for subtype and various different tumor
characteristics, but we know that these are very different diseases, and
so we usually take the approach of stratifying. Have you considered that?
Because I'm wondering if some of these differences are being driven by the fact
that there's a higher incidence rate for certain, especially
hormone negative tumors in the African population.
Yeah. It's a great question. And you may recall that when I
talked about the-- Thanks. When I talked about the models, I talked about a
general set of models that had the same covariates for all the cancers, and then
there were cancer specific models as well as stratification.
So we did do that stratification for breast cancer.
And
these results don't exactly make sense, but it doesn't seem like it was
driven by the stratification. But I wouldn't take that
as dispositive by any means, right?
So, I tried to tell a very tidy story, and there's lots
of limitations, especially in the TCGA data.
And one of those is that it's not a representative sample, right?
Yeah.
So when we do epidemiology, we want to have a representative sample. It's not.
The great thing is all the multi-omics data.
So we did do stratification. It doesn't show what you suggested, but I
remain unconvinced.
So then my follow-up question was for the first talk, and
I think it's amazing to remind us that we still have a lot to
learn about the genome. And I'm curious, when you
look at these different references,
when it comes to cancer, we see certain
differences by different populations.
And I'm wondering if there's any inkling that these regions where we're not
getting as good coverage or where you see some better coverage with the
newer references, are they in certain regions that we already
know or it's more enriched in these things that are complete black
boxes that might give us some new insights into, I guess, genetic regulation
and other types of molecular
characterization?
Yeah. Thank you. That's a really interesting question.
I think
the HLA locus was pretty much expected.
I think even before I opened my mouth or we looked at the data, you would have
expected that locus. I think moving
forward, the rest are really unknowns and
underappreciated. So in the next phase of this work, we'll be
going back to
reuse public data or publish data
to look at that question of does this really impact loci that
are really known to be associated with different cancer traits?
Here we just did a proof of principle in a couple of hundred samples, but we want
to go more full scale and look in depth especially in oncology
cohorts.
I had a follow-up question for Dr. Chambwe in regards to that, because
the population you used was asthma
at-risk individuals. And I'm wondering if you could share
with us really having data on a healthy population,
how could that impact in categorizing the
genetic ancestry and at-risk
variants or SNPs?
Right. I think,
yeah, the genesis of where those contexts came
from came from an asthma cohort.
But I think overall, where the
sequences map to in newer references points to a
generalizable feature of what those sequences are
in terms of particularly coverage around centromeres and telomeres,
but also in and around specific loci.
It's hard to say without actually doing the work, but I would
hypothesize that it also covers other predisposition
loci for different conditions or traits.
Yeah. On that very same issue, the HLA really jumped out to me as well,
and I appreciate the comment about, "Oh, we might've thought that." Anyway.
So one of the things that's happening, like with the traditional reference genome,
we think about it as a linear string. A haploid reference.
And with the new pangenome work, they're completely changing bioinformatically how
they represent the genome. And now we have these really complex graph
structures that can better accommodate allelic diversity.
So you get the branching at the regions that have a lot of allelic diversity.
And of course, HLA has just tremendous allelic diversity, especially for
populations from pathogen-rich regions.
So I'm wondering if you think of
how much of what you see at the HLA region might have to do with
the inability of the traditional
linear reference genome paradigm to accommodate
that kind of diversity.
It has a lot, I would say, mostly to do with that.
And so
one thing I didn't really get into was that moving forward, you'd really want
to consider using a graph genome as a reference because all the
different
alleles at different loci would be represented in the graph.
There's just a little bit of a delay in uptake because the downstream
tools to support pangenome alignment data
are not yet quite in place. There's a couple of different posters I've
seen at this meeting that are developing new tools for downstream analysis based
on graph alignments. So that stuff is coming along, but I
think
the HLA, it's really that question of the linear
representation just constrained your
ability to capture all those different haplotypes at these highly
polymorphic loci. And so it really was not
conducive. But I think what we are trying to do here is also raise awareness
that it's not something you think about.
You just do your analysis and you roll it out, and you don't think about those
reads that didn't map and what it means.
So I think coming back to even doing a local graph
alignment around particular loci of interest could also be a
strategy.
Before we take the next question, I want to also just, since this
particular part of our session is about genomic discovery to policy and
practice, I want to bring us back to even around the conversation you're having
right now, the fact that
both
Dr. Jordan and Dr. Chambwe, your
talks really sort of highlight how
omission or missing information
could potentially not just be about inclusion in terms of fairness,
but inclusion as scientific validity or
rigor. And I wondered if in
the sort of
questions that you've just been asking, you both reflect a little bit on
why these approaches shouldn't be sort of considered a
niche concern. Because, for instance, Dr.
Chambwe, you showed that even after using
HPRC, there were still unmapped
reads. There was still missingness in the references.
So as this is central to the future of precision
oncology, maybe you can just bring us back
to that. What are your thoughts about how we should start talking about these
omissions in the context of rigor?
Thank you, Dr. Davis, for that question.
Yeah, I think the bottom line is
that when we think in terms of precision oncology,
we're thinking of the maximum benefit we can give to different
individuals using these new advanced technologies and
methodologies. So I think this consideration of what the
impact of that reference would have on
different groups based on their inherent genetic
variation across populations is really important.
And so highlighting instances where
these missing sequences would have a significant clinical impact
moving forward would help perhaps move this discussion from a
fringe analytic technical concern to
really a mainstream
overlooked data stream, perhaps.
Yeah, that's a very provocative question. I mean that in the good way.
I have too much to say on that, so I'll try to keep it brief.
But I think that
we think about the genomics research gap, right?
The reality that still to this day, the vast majority of clinical genetics research
has been done on cohorts of European ancestry.
And if we talk about precision medicine and the benefit of precision
medicine, there's a very real possibility for those
populations that are underrepresented that currently bear the
highest burden of disparities not to benefit from that.
And that's the case that's been made. It's a totally valid case.
It's kind of the obvious one.
But the reality is that we're in this new normal, right?
In terms of the funding environment and the climate.
And I think it would behoove the disparities community to think
about
framing the benefit of inclusiveness,
inclusivity of a broader genomic reach
beyond just disparities in terms of
benefit to all of humanity, right?
Because what's happening is if you're just capturing a small slice of
the genomic diversity that's out there, you're leaving so
much on the table that could benefit
all of humanity. So I think both for a strategical
reason, as I mentioned, with respect to the new environment and making the case
for disparities research, making the case in closing the genomics
research gap.
I don't know if it's a paradigm shift, but maybe broadening the paradigm a little
bit could be helpful. So yeah.
Dr. Davis touched on some of what I was going to ask about because I work in
ovarian cancer, and it's just really generally understudied,
and we don't see as many...
It's hard enough to get samples in general, but samples from these
communities. So I was wondering if you think that the
mapping would be just as beneficial, like going backwards to
maybe parse out
some differences,
really small differences that we see from our mostly white and
European
samples, or if
going a different avenue would maybe be better with such small sample
sizes.
Yeah, I also work on another cancer type that's
data poor in a sense. I think
in that environment, in that context, it's helpful
to go back because that data already exists while
still trying to rectify the underrepresentation
or lack of representation of certain
populations in the available
broad genomic data scope. So I think both have
a say or potential to make advances in a given field.
I think one of the things too that came to light as I
was listening to
the talks is how there's an
intersectionality across the board of everything that you guys are
talking about. So, Dr. Jordan, you're bringing to
light how the reflexive thought about differential
expression or disparities has been centered on
genetic background, in the context of population diversity,
but now reminding us that it can be epigenetic.
And then in some of Dr. Chambwe's data, even though maybe she didn't get to get
into it too deeply, we also know that some of those regions that
are not explicitly annotated in hg38 or
T2T are enriched with CpG islands.
And so then there's sort of this
cross chasm of it could be epigenetic, but it'll also be
in regions that we don't even see yet.
And right now, epigenetics research tends to still lean
towards using platforms that are still sort of designed
using the references that we-- So CHIPS, for
instance. So I wondered, Dr. Jordan, if you could talk a little
bit more about how you think pangenomes is going to inform
epigenetic
mechanisms. And then I think I saw another question there.
Yeah. So, it's precisely analogous to what
Dr. Chambwe showed with respect to the mapping of RNA secrets.
So the data that I showed today are CHIP-based, right?
So they're going to be biased, and they're going to be limited.
But the field, I think, is moving much more towards bisulfite
sequencing and other sequence-based methods for
epigenetics, whether we're talking about DNA methylation or CHiP-seq with histone
modifications. So in all of those cases, just as
we saw that you're going to get better mapping or mapping of RNA secrets that you
previously just threw out and didn't even think about, I believe that the same
thing should, in principle, happen with epigenetic
sequence-based data
Right
And then for chips, the chips have the advantage of being more
cost-effective, then that would circle back to the chip design.
So when you're designing these chips-
Right. Okay
... if you want to have a multi-ethnic chip, then you should certainly take into
account variants and parts of the genome that are left out of
HG38 or HG19 for that matter. Yeah.
Right. Because we want to make sure that whatever we find here becomes clinically
usable, implementable.
That's right.
And we are probably still yet many, many years away from
everyone having bisulfite sequencing on their whole genome, let alone their
whole genome being sequenced. So I think coming back to the
tools that we use, being more informed in the design
could probably help with some of that
translatability of what you're finding.
Absolutely. Although, I do think that more and more the bottleneck is on the
analysis side. We heard that with respect to the pangenomes too, the
graphs. The sequencing is just getting cheaper all the
time. The analysis, people are costly.
Maybe AI will help us with that. Maybe not. I don't know.
Well, go ahead.
I had a question for Dr. Yates. As you know,
your work is really close to allow precision oncology on
prostate cancer, and I'm wondering, in addition
to integrating the DPI,
but thinking, from discussing epigenetics, is there data
sets that could be used, dietary consumption, regions,
that would obviously influence the biology of the tumor more
or less depending upon the genetic ancestry, and
how do you integrate that in looking at therapy?
Oh, wow. That's a great question. So, I think back
to... And I'll hopefully segue back into the epigenetic part of it.
We see that dietary factor. I don't know how many
prostate cohorts really have that level of information.
It's kind of why we did the Maryland cohort because
we're trying to have this sort of multilayered analysis.
But absolutely, we know those dietary factors.
We have been starting to explore exposures, though, so with Dr.
Davis and Niesh as well.
We're starting to understand what exposures and environmental exposures look like
as far as in... I had it grayed out on my
list of omics, but we actually have exposomics data showing that
environmental exposures, particularly in these neighborhoods, are also influencing.
So now we're going to have to include diet at some point.
Probably should be our next grant, right?
Award. But, I think it's incumbent of us to create these
cohorts to be able to tease this out, because I don't think we would've gotten here
without this multilayered analysis.
Excellent.
Really, I thank
all the speakers. Thank you so much.
That was very informative and certainly convinced me that your
genetic ancestry really determines
you being at risk for certain diseases.
But before we even get there, that perhaps we need better
references in defining it, and when
we're using genomic approaches and we're matching patients' tumor
samples and with the references,
there's a significant gap, an opportunity
in allowing true precision oncology across broad
populations. And not only in treatment, but actually even in
prevention strategies. So I'd like to thank for the
privilege of co-chairing this with Dr.
Davis, who's a thought leader on the topic, but also our three
phenomenal speakers.
Thank you once again.
Hope everyone enjoys the session.
I don't know if our speakers have any last thoughts they want to share.
If not, thank you all for joining us